it's starting to cool down in the valley
maybe not
maybe not
that cold but not the cold behind us the
ice rink has returned though to the
cosmopolitan on the strip for the 10th
season wow 10 magical years and bianca
holman is live this morning to share
more it is a family-friendly activity
and that's a good thing because some of
us are not very good ice skaters and
well we're going to put you to the test
apparently bianca how's your skating yes
all right heather john i'm not an expert
like you so i do have um this little
dolphin here just in case i slip right
okay i did sign the waiver though uh so
you can see that we're out here on the
ice and i'm wondering
was this place it was a pool so did you
freeze the pool fedora well obviously we
freeze the pool no
i'm just kidding we drain the water we
bring a bunch of equipment in it takes
about three weeks we start around
halloween and we usually finish up on
this time yeah and this is a beautiful
view so when people are out here they've
laced up their skates or you know but
fasten their skates there's a lot of
things that they can enjoy so i
understand you all have movie nights out
here with holiday movies mondays and
tuesdays
this movie starts around seven o'clock
everything from polar express to elf
national lampoon's holiday vacation
classic new holiday movies you can enjoy
fire watch the movie at a fire pit take
a reservation get some dinner
some holiday treats maybe a drink
campfire delight
it's fun and this has really become a
tradition here you know families come
out you know if you're from the east
coast i know a lot of people are
wondering can they drive the zamboni
right
that's you can definitely tell someone
from the east coast if they want to do
that but yeah we you know um
again it's a it's a great holiday
installation it's a real environment
you've got the you're overlooking the
strip on the fourth floor we make it
snow
something that i think
families will enjoy and we hope they
come out this season yeah and i
understand you know what there's
probably nothing like it here like an
elevated ice rink here on the strip
where you can see it this is unique to
the cosmo
yeah i don't think there's i know in las
vegas there isn't on a rooftop and i
can't think of many rooftop rinks
anywhere it is a real surreal location
and and it's
uh one one of a kind all right so again
it's great that it opens up today and
then it lasts until the new year so of
course i know you have extended hours
when kids get out of school so if you're
looking for something to keep the kids
busy of course coming out here and
enjoying all the things that uh they
have to offer here at the cosmos so
we're gonna send it back to you guys in
the studio uh i am gonna continue to
practice john so i can go up against you
i mean you skate every weekend so can
you blame me no no no no i love that
you're on the ice it's all good you got
the little help from the the seal i
think you had there so uh you're on the
right track that's how i learned how to
ice skate i learned how to skate not
with a seal when you were four with a
chair oh when you were four
when john was this tall
he's like oh when i was a mere tot i was
using that
good stuff bianca thank you very much